[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Ericson alongside Gregory Alba I
said your name for said my name how you
doing good don't woman expain my name
well now do it every time all right
nobody likes hearing you go over and
over Gregory ala everyone's like yeah we
know it's better if I do it I rarely say
my name they're going to leave it
they're going to leave it in the
comments he doesn't need to say his name
cuz he's so
famous leave a comment
I mean you guys can join in and be like
yeah t should always say his name
because she's cooler and also don't
forget to ring the
bell the B we're watching 47 MERS down I
forgot to say that at the top oh my God
we're watching that and it has a shark
and Manny Moore in it I just remembered
our friend Roxy strier she's close
friends with the director of this movie
really yeah that means we got a crap on
it so we don't look like we're sucking
up you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
we don't need we're not going to suck up
Roy CU she's got a cool friend who
directs movies Roy to the director to
the director right the direct we don't
know the know the director we don't know
their name but we're not going to suck
up to them we'll tell you that much okay
yeah sucker but you know you know who we
will suck up to the super super sexy re
because you guys are on patreon and we
love you so much thank you for joining I
mean you guys get to watch and sync up
with your full own copy me watch me and
gray we watch 47 meters down basic
almost all of it when you become super
sexy and you get on the patreon Greg and
John offer exclusive watch alongs and
highlights on patreon so you got to get
on there to get the exus a shter way of
saying it brilliant yeah right and I
didn't even look at the page look at the
page because I if I did I would have
said read out loud nope nope no I took
go away we this intro is long okay we
got to get to it 47 me down let's
go
oh man we're getting right to it we're
already underwat wonder how down we are
at this point how many meters you think
we are at this point oh
meters this movie is dark yeah it's
going to look just like this the whole
time with our reflection right in the
television okay liking that music yeah
it's dread
heavy
whoa that's pitch black right now right
now I see some
bubbles oh my
god oh thank God well it is throwing you
into the abyss now I'm with
it oh that is a cool opening actually
showing you just how terrifying the
the yeah while we vacation up above oh
and it's got a drink holder cool
Johannes Roberts let's give it up
johanes let's give it up let's give it
up man Johannes you know you ever need
an
[Music]
actress oh that's who was down
there oh cool reveal they were they're
just in a pool I love it
neat shk got you are serious look what
you did I'm going to go back to the room
I told steart I'd give him a call yeah
what's mny morbin up to that one show
that makes you cry every episode when
you watch it very popular once some
emies Ah that's clever the wine the wine
making the blood effect I get what
you're doing give it up for joannis
Roberts Direction
bra it's called foreshadowing thank you
so much for bringing me on vacation it's
going to be the best time ever ain't
nothing bad going to happen here today
do it Stuart is missing out I'm way more
fun anyway you are that look made it
seem like there's trouble in the water
nicely their relationship nicely done
this relationship is sinking oh what's
wrong what wrong
Lisa it's Stuart I lied about what
Stuart I lied about why Stuart isn't on
this trip what do you mean he's not
working he left
me he left to be Kate oh wow I really
called that you're good at predicting
seconds for their reveal terrible he got
bored he actually said that yeah that's
cruel and then I thought if I came on
this trip and I came away with you and I
had fun and I showed that I could be fun
somehow you would come back that's sad
well are you taking social media
photos to show just how great your life
is post breakup you and I are going out
it's 1:00 in the morning please said
it's Mexico you and I are the only ones
who aren't out come on yeah dude it's
safe for two white women to go venturing
around Mexico at one in the morning
a.m. come on have some fun post breakup
fun oh you brought two boys back to the
beach with you huh best night I could be
here all night girl is a morning they
really keep establishing this is a great
day it was bad in the beginning but it's
gotten good
Lisa you look desperate you look
desperate Lisa Lisa social media photos
like he said oh oh oh oh down ni rough
guys are inane seriously you have to try
we do it almost every weekend it's
amazing scuba diving 25 foot gr West
they come right up to your cage 25 never
seen anything like it like $100 each we
we know Taylor is like a friend of ours
no d That's sheep yeah get in there swim
with some sharks you're only down 5 m
totally safe exactly it's like you're
going to the zoo except you're in the
cage yeah and an underwater sweet sauce
better know so you could just think of
the photos they won't be the type of
photos that a boring person can take
boom he called it look who's having fun
now with great whites yeah that's right
[Music]
okay I would die to get a selfie with a
great white in the background oh me too
I'm sure we could Photoshop it no I want
it to be real yeah wanted to say I had a
really good night tonight me too yeah
yeah have fun come on kiss
him come on and hisy girl oh God no it's
okay it's fine see you tomorrow tomorrow
for sure come on oh how upsetting oh
girl just been she was trying to make
out with that guy from the night to the
morning to the next night and still
won't kiss oh okay oh yeah that's what
I'm talking we go whoa whoa whoa Kate I
don't know about this it'll be fun
hola CH hey how's it
going hey how are you I don't know who
the actress opposite of Manny Moore is
but I really like the two of them
together they feel like really
believable as friends yeah I agree like
they've been friends for a while I just
heard horror stories about Taurus going
on these Shady trips and Stuart
even anything steuart has to say is
invalidated now he's he's dead to you
girl come on now hola H I like him
Matthew MO Dean you both know how to
scuba dive right yeah yeah MH MH girl
you going to have a panic attack
underwater if it's a first time you put
on scuba GE all right well welcome
aboard that sounds horrify have you done
it I've never done it well I got
certified as a rescue scuba diver cuz I
was a dolphin trainer what oh man well
now your life is way more exciting here
when I was 20 and 21 y'all oh so like 40
years ago exactly a lifetime
ago first time I got in the pool scuba
gear on I was like no I
can't well look at this janky ass
boat you look like Ikea chairs on the on
the you look like you're modern-day
Pirates going to have the time of your
life I'm
scared damn this water is gorgeous
yeah damn they do not clean that boat
cast Matthew mod in anything and he just
seems suspicious this is it yeah this
is it's pretty unnerving shoing time
hungry oh boy e feeding
time I don't think I'd want to do this I
thought it was legal to CH the water
think I should Callie CH Mr
CH
hello God oh hickey I wouldn't want to
do it in my here with this Rusty
Cage yeah they just put that down smell
it should be here soon I do think it is
doing a good job in building tension I
prefer the movie when it doesn't have
music playing yeah I agree a sense of
the atmosphere and the mood there look
where there
hey it's Ming
fast oh my God this is
amazing pull it together Lisa I'm sorry
I'm sorry don't be mad at me I can't
you're not going to make Stuart jealous
with photos inside the boat's B I
started to become manipulative have fun
Bo don't
slip that cage looks so unreliable yeah
that's what I'm saying it's Rusty as
hell so
Rusty like and those Cliffs look like
they're plastic at top I'd be like
no I wouldn't even be the captain just
standing on top of this
cage how would you know for sure the
shark is in their proximity where they
can see it yeah the waves like under
like the Rippling maybe my God it's huge
oh well let's get you suited up
now I'm really nervous you are mhm I'm
shooting bricks wow Johannes Roberts was
respectful enough to not show them like
in a bikini right give it up for respect
give it up for
respect waited 20 whole minutes for that
shot and uh didn't get it calm down okay
yeah I'm okay
good
that's it okay I should have worn my
headband wear a headband every video one
time I don't wear a headband where a
character has a headband he's one uping
you right now check your air you should
both have 200
bar she's like down to 100
200 that's your air she going to run out
of air in 2 seconds she going to go down
there and have a panic attack if you get
any pain in your ears you just need to
equalize what is that til your head back
in does that really work well it'll pop
the pressure in your ears it builds up
up oh cool trust me once you're down
there you're not going to want to come
back up
right care it's great you're going to
love it down there
next be careful I know I saw the trailer
years ago but I don't remember anything
about what's supposed to happen me
neither miles away since if you're
frightened or
weak track you down great pep talk sir I
I want to go on do this with that guy
right there yeah right instill as much
fear into me as possible before I do
right before you got got to go down and
get
it what are we doing Kate
smile put it around your wrist girl
shouldn't they be in the cage as it's
descending I mean we're switching it up
now I guess with these oh okay the foot
it's tension building is what we're
doing
here once you take the first breath in
the suit like that there's no way she's
just going to be breathing normally it
feels so
weird ah creepy H never done anything
like this of the sort this is really
unsettling for
me ah I like that obscuring the vision
even more down we
go You Can See For Miles Kate look at
the fish do you see all the fish my
hands would not be on the bars hell no
I'm good actually I can't see any sharks
all right well just be p we're going to
add a little bit more CH to the water
now no that's horrible I would just be
happy with the fish yeah it kind of
takes your breath
away well that's not what you
want what is it coming it's going to
come right from the
bottom I love that they're capturing The
Wonder of it though Che
hi take me back steart take a picture of
me wait no that's why you're supposed to
put the rubber band on your
wrist you got to go
get that awesome that is actually scary
as hell God oh my
God that is
scary would the shark have eaten the
cell phone I don't think so this is
amazing uhoh I would hate this so much I
would not not do it I have decided I
would think it's cool but we all know
Chum's going to get in the water he's
going to start to get feisty and they're
going to be like where's that food at I
can't believe how close they are I dare
you to touch him no no why would you do
that you don't do that steart can't even
see
that there's two of them they're so fast
you touch one he can bite your the other
one can bite your arm off girl oh he
definitely likes to look at
you of course I think the cage just
dropped a little bit no no it's the
Wench mechanism it's it's fine it just
slipped a little bit uhhuh I'm sure it's
nothing we're fine okay are you crazy
this is when I go up would like to come
back up now please all right listen
stand
by sorry said come on oh no the shark's
going to knock them down or some
right oh God I just don't feel safe in
this
cage at least we got to see some sharks
I mean I guess so you guess so on is out
can I go back down
again so it's the the rest of the movie
them just talking about it nope there's
the rest of the
movie
sayara
help whoa how many meters down you think
they're going to
go oh my God that is actually 47 that's
actually really
scary oh
no ah oh
yeah girl don't be screaming your
air is
gone that is a very no thank you oh my
God
no that is rough you going so fast like
you're that would be so
painful tilt your head
back no oh that's clever that foot out
that's clever oh my God damn that is so
scary that is really
scary oh my god oh holy junk that's
terrifying that is really really
freaking
scary oh my God oh my
goodness oh God if it keeps falling and
it breaks the
cage oh
god oh my god oh wait till steuart hears
about
this maybe they can find their camera
down there yeah the shark ate oh no the
shark ate it that's right I remember
there drop hope for steart believing
them
[Music]
now that's a very unique claustrophobic
situation because it's open exposed yet
you're trapped
oh damn is there mask filling up it's
probably cuz it's very cold down there
when you get lower like that shots are
weird what are we looking oh it's like a
extreme close of her face okay got it a
lot of it is very disorienting
[Music]
close-ups oh
no scary she's she got she got injured
my God and now we've got natural Chum in
the
[Music]
water 100% pure human Chum just swimming
around out there now look at me stop
stop you want an adventure hey girl you
got to calm down you're going to lose
all your air she's going to be at 50 in
minutes Andy Moore is really good at
sell in that
Panic can you hear that
tayor help us hello this must have been
a complicated ass movie to shoot we must
be just out of range of
transmission we've got to try and get my
contct with them how whoa the hell maybe
we're just a bit too deep maybe maybe if
I swim up a tiny bit him up nope this is
a bad idea I would just yeah but what
about the Sharks you know what I do I
take my mask off and let myself drown
they know you're down there they know
they dropped you I won't leave you I
promise I
promise girl sh stuck well good you
shouldn't be swimming up
there why would you attempt it's not
they know that they dropped I just feel
like they're going to eventually rescue
us I mean do it do you think these are
the kind of guys who would go out of
their way to rescue them uh well if
those two guys want to get laid yes I
can get it just give me a
second get your feet out of there I
think I can get out through these bars I
need to take my tank off though
yes I need you to watch out for me
please be
careful oh yeah she can definitely fit
through that part of it oh my God this
is just why are we doing this this is so
scary I would not do God this is insan
this is really really tense oh my God
you are literally like that's what they
look for the movement I can't I don't
you do the exact movement to attract
them what are we going to do I'm going
have to take my mask off okay no
no way I'm sure if you push it up enough
you could squeeze through if you're both
pushing I'm going to take it off and go
through and you're going to pass it
right to me okay if you can't get it
back on again you'll drink
drown the two of them together are is
very very good
yeah wow how horrifying girl get that
mask on Purge that water out of
[Music]
there wow no Cuts that's great yeah
that's good you can like actually see
the struggle is freaking real okay we
didn't see her but the straps behind her
head but that's
fine uh
no is it a mislead is it a mislead oh
God God and now you don't have
protection from the cage cuz you can't
get back in this is just oh no blonde
girl's totally dead like maybe not right
now but at some point in this movie
she's dead in five minutes let's keep a
look out
okay well un yeah un try that good good
good damn I love the look of this movie
movie like the isolation and the bubbles
that's really it looks really cool I
think I have it
free is that a oh God it was just her I
like it's just her I was like oh my God
is a shark you got it you got
it yeah good job
Kate I'll wait to go Kate heck yeah Kate
oh my
God I'm going to see if I can reach the
get get back in the cage hurry please
now she's going at the
top God that is that is terrifying po oh
boy they really know it is well captured
it's really well captured oh my God so
scary
God just that Bleak desolation just not
knowing how much further you have to
go
K can you hear me it's it's K
hello you have to help us are you both
okay yes good yes how much air do you
have in your tank um I'm at 55 bar uhoh
I need you to get back in the cage
immediately it's the only safe place
from the Sharks you understand Javier's
coming down to you now he's going to
hook up the cage to our spare wed feels
like a a Universal Studios theme park
that you would go on don't try to race
to the surface you'll get the BS yeah
I'm going back down now promise me I'll
come just stay in the cage and reserve
your air God I hate
this oh God the
bubbles it's doing an excellent job on
capturing that Terror of a shark can
come at any moment right now like the
amount of tension I feel on my stomach
is it's a
lot do we make a plot prediction right
now I feel like she's just going to see
blood coming down up in the cage and is
gonna know well Kate's dead I feel like
Mandy she'll be Mandy Moore will be
isolated and then towards the finale she
will finally just like go I'm gonna go
make a break for it and oh yeah oh
she'll have to make a break for it
because she'll almost be out of hair cuz
she's a panic she's Miss panic I like
that let's see how this goes yeah that's
Prett we need Sur okay and by that point
she'll be dead blond girl it's over but
I don't want her to die I'd be happy if
the movie let her live I really like her
character the other night at the hotel
what did you mean when you said that
your relationship was the only thing you
were good at you're always doing such
fun stuff Kate I could never compete
with that my relationship with Stuart
was the one thing I had that you didn't
H we were never in
competition maybe you weren't I like how
they wrote the younger sister to be more
like the older sister sister what do you
think steuart would say if he could see
you
now Mandy Moore is so cute and so pretty
yeah men don't
Chaser what is
that I think you know exactly what that
is it's the show you've been waiting for
oh my God that's the boat's engine oh my
God they've left us they they wouldn't
have left us okay maybe it was a
different vote I mean they probably need
something in order to they have to
probably leave to go back you
know my God this going out of the cage I
mean it's probably better for their
business if they just let them
[Music]
die I love these wide shots over there
like tiny obscured oh yeah God byebye in
one bite right
I'm
scared can you hear me hello there no no
no I'm like someone answer
me
oh that that dreed
man oh my God hair all over my body is
God oh my God the chain oh God move the
chain H
H oh my
God that was that's really
scary I thought I was dead oh my God is
the oh my God oh my God that's so scary
okay just going to R it's going to get
through oh my God he's going to eat
through the freaking
cage who
W that is massive hole in your oh my
gosh it almost broke through the cage
we're not safe here anymore this is
where they have to okay we cannot just
swim up no we can't we will get the bend
it's nitrogen bubbles in the brain the
only way to go up is to ascend slowly
with a decompression stop for 5 minutes
unprotected in open water well well
scripted they had to really learn their
for this movie this movie is really
selling me on the possibility that they
both die by the end yeah yeah it says 80
bar I don't know what that means this
that means we have about 20 minutes tops
before we run out what what about you
she's see now I think she's just going
to sacrifice herself give her the oxygen
well I think she's just G to how many 10
she's used up a lot she exerted her
physical suffocate to death yeah
Javier is that Javier tell you I
wouldn't be talking I'd be doing
straight up
meditation oh thank goodness yeah it's
all going to pan out Sarah right
now that guy's going to get
eaten is he just diving without any
protection there's got to be no way you
can't free dive that far or are they
just descending I you you can obviously
but like why wouldn't he have can they
maneuver the cage over to there like
within it you know what I mean oh like
them push it yeah no they would be out
of they're already out of
air I mean they have lights on the cage
you should be able to see
that uh-oh uhoh you see that it's just
falling well if he heard us why didn't
need to Signal we need to get that winch
cable I love that they've kept it just
in their perspective this whole time 17
bar you're almost out of air don't
remind her okay I'm yeah you got to just
swim up and you got to wait need to tell
me exactly what I need to do oh she's
going to rise to the occasion keep as
close to the ocean floor as you can
sharks attack from blow so if you keep
to the floor you should be fine that
shark seem to be attacking right from
the side there this button inflates your
BCD use it to go up this button deflates
it do not go straight up you will die do
you understand so she's just going
parallel to try to find the flashlight
guy I think so yeah okay that's good
you're doing so good okay
keep your breathing slow damn how do
they film this this is really well done
it's awesome they build some weird set
it's probably just in
the Universal
[Music]
fool oh that is so scary that's awesome
oh no girl why you going fast like that
oh trying to get to a hiding spot yeah
yeah okay I'm just like frantic swimming
oh God I think it's
gone skip too it's not
gone
[Music]
yeah Lisa what's going
on Lisa are you okay I I like how the
sound design isn't overly
accentuated woo striking that bounce
between like Hollywood and realism with
the shark yeah like with the real sound
and sometimes the music the intensity
comes in and then I kind of like it
though when it's like just the the water
and the breathing and the yeah like it's
scary as hell has a mood here I can see
the flashlight I can see the beam it's
getting
close oh my
God I what's wrong oh it's way deeper
got it I'm at the edge you some sort of
Cliff I can't see the ocean floor that
is horrifying oh God yeah
God okay I can do this no oh my
god oh oh I am stressing out y'all oh my
God this flashlight is going to be like
in the water and no one's going to be
attached to it and I'm going to freak
the F
[Music]
out is she still within range to talk to
her sister I don't even I see it I guess
so I see
it congratulations I found the
flashlight we didn't need a
flashlight oh my God I am so
upset stay
calm oh my God how FR just start oh my
God this is
terrifying oh no I hate this
shot whoa
oh my God this is wild I hate everything
about this there's like a great trickery
on your mind where makes you think
you're seeing something so
claustrophobic like oh
god oh my
[Music]
god oh no
what why did he just descend like by
himself down there knowing there's shark
wait was that that was her sister right
no no no no it was one it was the
guy Kate Kate I can hear you can you
hear me why does this have a 5.6 R IMDb
this is really well done I don't know
it's like it's like really well done I
need you to b a rock or something when
you see the flashlight so I know which
way to go me that Echo hear you
Kate no no
he's got no hair oh you better get away
from that blood
girl okay all right all right okay good
thinking good thinking good thinking
good okay good thinking good thinking
take everything yes never leave a weapon
behind good girl give me the flashlight
I'm going to swim back up and tell them
that we have to come up now be careful
I'll be right back you better go slow oh
wow you super Brave Taylor hello this is
Hypnotic it's Lisa we managed to attach
the cable to the top of the cage we need
to come up right now jaier is dead get
back in the cage now I'm bringing you
back up I would start bringing it up as
she's swimming
down
whoa oh my God is Kate like almost dead
there's excellent camera work
here did you hear that oh
God is it going to break on those oh
There She Goes
see look we're starting to move maybe
the shark is going to knock it off
there's like how many sharks two well at
least from when we at the top I think
there was two yeah she's not going to
make it she doesn't even have enough air
to go I'm so stressed
out
44 hang on Kate we're at 36
M 35 it's too soon it's too soon I don't
like
it oh God here we go
again you got to be sh Groundhog Day for
real oh my God this is just terrible
maybe get out of the cage and grab onto
the Rope M okay get on to the cage and
grab onto the Rope yep yep
yep go
oh my God oh my God this is not real
Kate's Dead Oh Kate's way dead Kate is
dead right now she's going to die now
her sister's going to have to make
decision if she's going
to oh my God it just keeps getting
worse we're running out of time I've got
to get a hold of Taylor Don't Leave Me
Kate I'm going to suffocate Kate's gonna
suffocate she's literally two minutes
away from dying I'm going to send down
extra air tanks moving onto a second
tank is going to increase your chance of
nitrogen Narcosis dramatically okay make
sure that neither of you is behaving
strangely or
hallucinating what Coast Guard they're
sending a team that's fully equipped for
deep sea rescue they'll be here in less
than an hour less than an hour yeah what
what are you checking about you think we
got we got that kind of where's the
Coast Guard where was a coast guard the
second the thing broke off from your
ship
buddy catch catch is Kate not going to
make it back with them I mean she is
like she's practically dead this m i
feel like has been telling us this whole
time Kate's going to die
God I feel like out of all them Kate's
going to die yeah okay come on Kate get
to the
air great that light will not attract
any attention oh my God please don't die
in the midst of getting the air on I
would just instantly grab it and come
back no no no she's got to hook up
now I said that's a
flares good all we have to do is wait
for the Coast Guard to arrive are they
going to fall out is it going to get
what is this why we get the close up the
flares the flares are going to go
bye-bye can't get
down
[Music]
wow oh that's a cool shot the effects on
the sharks are great I was wondering if
they use like a shark head in that
beginning shot when he's biting the cage
it looked awesome I'm going to make a
break through the cage no Kate no no no
don't move stay down stay down this is
it open the hatch come out Kate oh my
god did he take her head off and with
the air and the flares oh God
God oh that's right she can't even get
to it yeah oh my God right her freaking
leg I forgot about that Holy I am not
going to die down
here she does have that gun though like
how could that t help her well I think
as she's ascending and then the shark's
about to kill her she uses the gun to
shoot it shot the Shar survives cuz it's
a movie I mean I was thinking maybe she
shoots it to get the air and pull it
back like not shoot the tank like use
the arrow to reel it in somehow you know
what I
[Laughter]
mean actually that makes a lot more
sense yeah girl you got to use the thing
and reach for the you could do it damn
it's right in
sight there you go Tera you're smart yes
yeah baby smart cookie
Tera God girl I swear to God if they
make it to where she grabs it and it
shoots through a freaking hand I'm going
to
die like I can't be doing that right
[Music]
now oh okay no I no of course
oh she hooks it to the netting come on
now hook that
netting oh wow this is like when I spend
$50 on those claw machines
yeah it's closer celebrate
[Music]
progress there we go that'll hook around
the thing good
job
okay God grab
it does she know how to switch sh out
that's the thing I'm thinking I'm like I
know her sister would
but come
on God now it's time to hallucinate
imagine having a conversation with
steuart in that cage let's go there
movie maybe he'd be like oh you're fun
now I'll take you back you're
interesting with a geving with the dead
Sister
Lisa Kate Lisa are you there no way W
okay I thought that you were dead she's
hallucinating I managed to escape I'm
hurt distracting more
sharks how much air do you have left
dirty bar oh this is good I don't know
if it's real or not she's going to have
to I think it's real yeah I I have no
idea if it why would they mention the
hallucination thing though I'm going to
come and get you I'm going to come and
find you right now just swim up
somebody's got to just swim up the rolls
are
switching
she can inflate it so it lifts it up use
the air in there I hope it doesn't pop
the thing but okay good good good yeah
yeah
[Applause]
yeah no
ow Kate keep talking to me please can
you see the be from my flashlight I see
you I see the flashlight yes okay I'm
coming to find you stay right where you
are just grab the spear in case would
she have weapon behind would she have
been able to escape that the shark you
mean the shark yeah yeah know I mean she
could just be like bitten and then you
know injured that's kind of all they do
to humans they just sort of like bite a
limb and they spit them
out oh she is bleeding so much how how
are there not like a crap ton of sharks
she said she's like the sharks are
surrounding me now
use the flare keate it'll help word off
the Sharks oh right would the flare ward
off the sharks or attract sharks I don't
know yeah I mean good question all my
knowledge of sharks comes from Cinema so
I have no idea what an actual shark is
like I can hear you okay um we are
heading up now no it's not safe you need
to stay in the cage this guy in the cage
no if you ascend too quickly you're
going to get the B look at your Gau tell
me what your depth is Mom we're at 30 m
dude I wouldn't even concern myself
we're at 20 M okay good now you need to
stay there for 5 minutes and do a
decompression stop you need to let the
nitrogen leave your blood
Stam Kate's having a lot leav her
bloodstream right now 4 and 1/2
minutes we need to let another one
hurry
oh no no no
no got it got it just three more
minutes oh my
God oh my
God what a reveal shot holy that
was so
[Music]
scary oh my
goodness what do we do break for the Sur
wait what they're dropping the
tanks they that close already guess
so
wow wow huh tiny bit of Hope oh my
goodness holy junk oh this would be so
great if the sharks ate them right here
right I would love it just killed him
off right
now okay gra
it oh
God oh my God you guys suck they suck so
hard I hate I hate all of them so much
do they have like anything on them to
fight them off go do they have anything
no there goes your leg oh who did he get
Mandy
right
yeah yeah yeah oh
goodness oh God that is you got to punch
him in the nose I've heard that actually
doesn't work yeah real hard I've have
heard
that
oh my
God oh my God
oh girl you're dead right no no no no no
oh he didn't even bite it
fully he just kind of oh my God oh my
[Music]
God oh at least you still got your body
parts oh never mind wrong about that she
like lose her whole leg she I mean I
assume so right unless they're
like how strange uh there she goes the
old bubbles in the brain she never made
it to the surface she never made it
A she never made it a man and her
sister's just what ly oh the whole thing
yep you were right yep oh we made
it we made
it
[Music]
oh you're
hallucinating it's got
funnye also like ju letter are
hallucinate I mean it we're way past
like the Coast Guard is here you are
going to be
fine why do all these guys die without
any like real
protection the important part is she had
the character Arc in her
mind
true it's a good story it's a good
hallucination that's
[Music]
tragic sister still saved
her one more let this be a hallucination
oh
go just a Time Loop of
hallucinations I'm really conflicted
about the ending is that it that's it
right they're not going to oh
man my I I want to I want to talk about
the positives first okay let's let's do
it I am extremely conflicted though
about the choice of the
hallucination and now I'm wondering if
that's where the as I was it kept
puzzling my mind of why is this like
IMDb rating like not as high as because
I was like this is a really well done
movie it's like really well done um but
anyway all right so why do you think the
IMDb is lower it'll because of the I I
feel like it's i' to be the thing about
the not as much sharks or specifically
the way the ending went down I I Don't
Know Jack about the audience response on
this movie I really don't I don't know
any specific so it is just a guess um I
will go into that later first things
first if you guys are listening to us on
Apple or Spotify real rejects podcast
please what did they do again well
they're supposed to ra it it R it is the
D oh God rate it um thank God here we
just watched 47 meters down let's recap
our our quick experience here uh I went
into this expecting a cheese fest and it
was anything but yeah it was intense it
was genuinely intense it felt grounded
and re like for someone who's never been
scuba diving even I know it's that
exactly the same thing C what this
called cage diving what is there a term
for this I guess that would be cage
diving right yeah uh someone who's never
done anything underwater in the middle
of the ocean kind of deal uh this felt
believable and realistic to me till it
got a little Hollywood with that's what
maybe was making me question it the
second Kate was alive was it because I
was like this is the one part of the
movie that's feeling very Hollywood to
be
um however I was like but I feel like
maybe the movie earned it because for
very related into the film so maybe it
turned it uh but overall as the movie
went I I found it very gripping and um
appropriately claustrophobic and I I
love the Desolation to it and it was a a
great aura of suspense and and uh you
know paranoia and it was really
FR tension throughout and you it's it's
like the the time was flying by yeah so
I I really really enjoyed it uh a lot it
was I was more impressed with it I
wasn't expecting to walk out saying that
I found a lot of this very impressive um
there is that one choice that I want to
go into about the ending with the
hallucination that that does kind of rub
me the wrong way yeah and I'll tell you
why later but I want to hear your
thoughts man I I'm a I'm claustrophobic
so those shots of her reaching the
Cliff's Edge were some of my favorites I
mean I it makes it throws you into it
and with the shots that they choose they
really do make you feel a sense of panic
which is you know I Bravo for doing that
because I think they're throwing the
audience into exactly the position they
want you to be in to really feel how
terrifying this is um and then uh my
favorite shot terrifi I jumped out you
could go back and Rewind it I literally
jumped out of my seat when the second
flare goes on and we see two sharks I
thought it was three or maybe it was
three I don't even know my brain was it
just the whole thing amazing and also so
scary and I can't yeah that was that was
such a great shot um what an awesome
reveal this was a lot of fun and it was
very grounded I mean the two actresses
did a great job oh yeah excellent
excellent yeah so so good and even at
the the top there it's like we got some
Foundation of her to for her to talk
about um Stuart and whatnot and I
steuart best off camera character in the
world yeah yeah I I feel like the the
beginning stuff my of of her the only
the one part that kind of bugged me that
I was like wait is this gonna be corny
when she first walked onto the dock and
she's we didn't really see the sign the
sign was just like on its side and that
that's what made her freak out where she
went oh God I don't know if I can do
this and I went like but really just cuz
the sign but anyway uh that part kind of
made me giggle cuz I was like wait where
are we going with this and then where we
headed was excellent like I loved it
just the top of the setup I I thought it
I I thought we were going to go into
corny cheesy land just a little bit
there was a few bits and pieces at the
top once we got in the water stuff's
great I loved it it was beautiful shots
and um yeah I mean for for the
ending uh I don't know I mean maybe
they're like hey we'll actually
see uh her fight out from if she goes in
the water again in 40 isn't there
there's another one right that they're
like oh we'll actually show it and she
won't be hallucinating because I would
have liked to actually see I don't know
her I don't know if the sequel brings
her back right I'm like but maybe maybe
she's dumb enough to go again cuz
everyone's like Mandy Mar we love you
it's probably someone else I know it but
whatever yeah I I mean yeah um it's got
a high Amazon rating though the yeah I I
love the music a lot too there was a
great sense of dread and I thought the
sound design was excellent they
especially a lot of this could have been
overly Punchy and super cinematic with
its sound design and here I think they
wanted to find that right balance
between something that is it's like
think of it think of the balance of
trying to find the the ground between a
realistic punch and then you know
because in real life there's not cool
sound effects when some when someone
gets punched you know yeah and having so
having that grounded especially when
we've seen sharks in so many movies
which the Roars and the thrashes are
usually so much more enunciated and here
it's not really there which make because
I thought they had a great job on
cutting between the perspectives of I
keep calling her m anymore what's the
character's name I know Kate because I
don't know the's name oh remember Lisa
Lisa hi Lisa um yeah Lisa and Kate
because yeah the like you said the
relationship between them was really
strong and I I loved how you know uh
Lisa was the older sister and and and
there was just enough character to get
you invested like I was I was genuinely
invested in them and I I was at the
point where I thought I was like okay I
my initial thought was pretty much what
happened that except except she yeah
they kind of they were subverting
expectations in certain directions um
but that Kate would die and that she mny
Moore would make it out alive but I
thought Mandy Moore would have like her
like I'm just gonna go for it moment um
which she does have but it's fake it's a
hallucination moment so yeah has it it
happens in you definitely called that
yeah it's still I it's the hallucination
part it does um throw a wrench in that
big time so I thought so I thought the
actors are really good and they I
thought they did an amazing job of these
because you can't see their faces for
most of it so so much has of it has to
be conveyed just in the delivery yeah
you know and and you really because in
order to feel the Panic of the situation
you have to feel what Mandy Moore is
feeling and I thought whoever played
Kate wish I learn her name whoever
played Kate she has to portray um
assuredness and and strength while also
clearly being ter provide at the same
time you so I thought it was really well
layered and I like the Arc of the jux
that's the part of it that bugs me about
the Hallucination is I think it really
undermines Mandy Moore's character Arc
because she doesn't actually have it she
she doesn't actually grow up to go I'm
I'm now at a position where I can take
care of this on my own right and get out
of it yeah and I think they have the
hallucination point because because the
hallucination happens the one part of
why I think the Hallucination is well
Justified is because when she saves
herself from getting lifted up from the
cage and then Kate for some reason is
not being devoured to death it when it
becomes very Hollywood at that point and
like oh shark's attacking me and let
like I but I was I was still believing
it when me too when when the shark was
attacki and then but you even pointed
out like oh they're at the surface
already like there was stuff here that
was starting to question the the a movie
that was making the validity of what we
saying exactly everything was very real
until here where it was interweaving but
I was so in the suspense of the moment
yeah and the hope of the moment that I
was like whatever it's a movie and I
want them to live so let's just roll
with it and then it kept having me in
the tug of war I thought was such a
great scene too of oh it's got her it's
she got away oh it's got her again then
she got away like it it was doing such a
great job with the Bel with even though
you had to suspect SP your disbelief it
would still pull you back in with the
with the um intensity of the situation
and the immediacy of it that everything
that was like critic critical of realism
I would just like disregard it for the
sake of the emotional catharsist that
I'm feeling in this moment and the and
the grip of Terror yeah but then when
you have the hallucination reveal I felt
like it
was um tragic for tragedy's sake and
nothing to really help serve the
character like I think it probably would
have been better if she hallucinated and
then she died yeah because like she was
just down there looking at her blood and
it that would have been a I kind of
imagine that too like it would have been
a sweet kind of a sweeter better sweet
ending where she's just seeing her blood
and she's saying like Kate we made it
and it's just we see a slow Dolly out
and it's like air is just surrounding
and that's that's it we go to blackout
you just you use your imagination right
having the the sense that at least she
died thinking that she had yeah that
that she was rescued yeah because I'm
like what's the point now because like
then the coast guards come just like a
second later and saver so um so to me I
didn't feel like it was NE it's like you
either stick with you either just give
us the ending that you made it that they
made it out or you give us the uh an
ending well that's why I thought how are
they they going to use her for two cuz
why do we have to see her still alive I
don't think she's I would not I can't
imagine she would do it again but maybe
she's like I still love Stewart man I'm
trying yeah I'm trying to I already done
this I I I live yeah so I think some PE
I I just to me personally I find the
choice a bit manipulative of oh look how
sad this is when I'm like no I mean
it kind of undercuts your movie and I'm
it what also undercuts the tragedy of it
is she's just saved later so she just
with the fact that her sister's dead
know I agree I I think it would have
been more um more sad more bsweet if she
was like I said you know she's she's
happily saying hey Kate we made it she's
at the bottom of the ocean imagining
she's happy with her sister but the
reality is she's going to die down there
and her sister's long gone this by
letting her live with the coast guards
pulling her out I'm like whatever yeah
yeah it doesn't make it as exciting
which is why I'm like and also in the in
the immediacy of the moment cuz I said
she's hallucinating but you said it's
too soon yeah I was like it too soon on
there does seem like timeline wise she's
hallucinating remarkably quick like in
the way the movie us away right yeah and
so it did that threw me off too but may
maybe that's how it is in real life I I
I have no idea I don't know either um I
also think with the sound real quick
that it was very subdue there was a
couple of times that I was going to say
I was going to be like this sounds like
a spa like when you go
spot and get a massage like it's like
meditative music and uh at first I was
like oh interesting choice I feel like
I'm walking in to get a very relaxing
massage but then that that it faded
quickly and I was like oh it really just
matches the serenity of what it feels
like when you're down in the ocean right
you're just surrounded by water it
really actually matched the vibe of what
we were um living in ju AOS to you are
also surrounded by these kind of killers
even though I think the the great white
sharks they they don't tend to like eat
humans in full they kind they'll damage
you bad to where you could die but they
don't they'll be like bye play with you
and be like you really don't taste like
seal so no thanks but um still it's
terrifying I liked uh the sound mixed
with like I said J's position of how
scary we're surrounded by these scary
sharks and when they came up I think
you're right about we didn't
necessarily the music didn't change we
just saw them it was revealed because we
were living in their in their space a
lot which I really enjoyed of just the
breathing and like holy crap we turn our
head and there's a shark and that made
it really really scary for me which is I
think what made the intensity bigger
anytime they would go out of the cage
they're surrounded by full water it
looks black dark and we're like a shark
could come at any moment and we know the
music is not going to lead us to
revealing that yeah that it's not going
to be like uh I agree because I mean we
joked about it at the top um you know
like uh that because we know roxxy's um
friends with the director right and
we're like we're not GNA kiss the
director's ass here and I I never would
um no I will say though like well but
the best part of the movie is the way
the movie is directed like the way the
movie is shot is is the best part of the
movie like working with the
cinematographer the it is so cleverly
done because anytime they step out of
the cave
the sense of surrounding is is just so
incredibly vast and dense that you and
and the perspective is so skewed and you
know that that like you can't really see
so you always get a sense that a shark
will appear at any moment and they
really do a great and this is something
that could have easily broached the
terrain of constantly feeling ridiculous
and feeling unbelievable but it managed
to give you just enough sense of the
scope and the distance and believability
when they were able to survive or hide
from a shark and a and also as someone
who doesn't like it seemed like you were
able to keep up with a a little bit more
than I was um just because you have
personal experience with all this stuff
where it was scuba diving and whatnot
and whereas I I'm like I'm learning all
this information for the first time
right but I was still able to keep up
with like the rules established of what
it takes to survive in a situation like
this and so there was a great grip on t
mention the editing was very solid
everything around the film making side
and the Performing was really great it's
really just the storytelling choice of
what they did with the ending that
rubbed me the wrong way um yeah the
Cinematic shots like when they would
choose to cut cuz we we deal in a lot of
extreme close-ups and extreme like not a
lot but Extreme when they would go back
to the Masters and they would reveal
just them in the middle of the water or
it's just them with their flare or it's
just them with those three sharks that's
wild I love how they utilize that right
where it's like we're very close in in
their world and then we we can get super
far out um
which this cinematography in here was
really great overall I thought it was
very I would give it it goes down I give
it like a seven out of 10 yeah I give it
like a seven like 7.5 I know was it went
down for me because the ending did not
rub me the right way so that's the only
thing that brought it down for me yeah
um otherwise I'd be like an eight and a
half but yeah I had like a 7.5 for it
yeah yeah I really think man if she was
just down there and she's like to seeing
her we know she's going to die down
there I'd be like oh man what a what a
film like but it makes it way it makes
it so much more sad but also so much
more realistic but that then the tragedy
of that would truly hit them as opposed
to this is just like Hollywood sad like
look how sad this is that she's I mean
she still gets to live but her sister
actually is dead is dead for like five
minutes she believed her sister was
alive and that she was a hero in this
yeah um yeah yeah I had fun though
it was fun it was a super fun movie I'm
I I did not expect it to be that good I
I wasn't sure what I was going into I
really didn't cuz like some of you know
some of the shark movies are like
they're not great and this one I had a
ton of fun so thanks for making it uh
any last words nope I'm good that is it
from from us we love you so much don't
forget to leave a like and a comment and
ring the bell we'll see you next
[Music]
time